over the years I built up quite the
collection of physics books these are
just some of them through my
undergraduate and my PhD in physics so
in this video I'm going to be
recommending 10 books in two categories
for those of you who are interested in
studying physics or for those of you who
are looking for a present for aspiring
physicist the two categories are books
which introduce concepts in maths and
science in a kind of general way popular
science books if you like and then also
textbooks which you might want to buy to
get ahead of the game and read before
you go to university and also do
exercises in and then also users of
reference during the beginning of your
course all the books I talked about will
have links to their Amazon pages down
there in the description and I'd also
recommend that you check out the
comments section where I'm sure that
everyone is posting their favorite
physics books to to kick things off I'm
gonna recommend five popular science
books starting with an absolute classic
six Easy Pieces by Richard Fineman so
Fineman wrote quite a few famous physics
books this was the first one that I read
and I also think it's the most
appropriate as an introduction over to
Fineman and to physics in general so
this book is formed of chapters taken
from his lectures in physics series
which is famous amongst physicists for
being really good and it offers an
introduction to areas of physics like
classical gravitation a little bit of
quantum mechanics where physics sits in
relation to other sciences and generally
it's just a really good introduction to
the field and it's for that reason that
I was given this about ten years ago at
a summer school at the University of
Oxford and that's why this copy is
particularly battered because I took
this everywhere with me when I was in
sixth form this thing is really concise
it made a big influence on me like it
definitely spurred me on to do physics
at uni I was pretty set by that point
but this was like yeah this there was a
particular moment in this actually to do
with the uncertainty principle right at
the end of the quantum mechanics section
when I was I I read something and I had
to tell everyone else about it so I I
really can't recommend this one enough
this is an excellent popular science
book and then a follow-up recommendation
like the sequel if you like six not so
easy pieces which is about relativity
which is a subject that isn't
in six easy pieces because it's not so
easy
this also draws on fineman's lecture
series but this time talking about
special and general relativity these are
done in like a depth that's not quite
the same as a physics degree but still
definitely more advanced than six Easy
Pieces so I'd recommend this to someone
maybe he was in high school who was
particularly advanced or someone who's
starting out a degree now this next book
isn't about physics it's actually about
maths it's Alex's adventures a
numberland by Alex bellos the reason I'm
recommending this book is because so
much of physics is really maths a
physics degree is basically a maths
degree with applications and if you
don't enjoy maths then you are kind of
at a disadvantage when studying physics
I'm saying that as somebody who didn't
enjoy studying maths until very
literally until I read this book this
book changed the way I thought about
maths it made it seem so much less
intimidating it made it seemed fun it
actually made me interested and it was
like a step change it was before about
this I just really didn't enjoy it that
much after this I have found physics
easier I have found working with the
maths in my degrees so much easier so
honestly this is one of the books I
recommend to everyone this this is one
that I genuinely think anybody studying
physics who like me wasn't particularly
keen on the maths part of it everybody
like that should read this book
next a lighter book but won't covering a
broad range of modern physics through
the lens of science fiction the physics
of the impossible by Michio Kaku I first
read this book relatively recently I
actually reviewed it on my Goodreads and
to be honest I wasn't expecting very
much from it I've read a lot of physics
books that I I'm a relatively advanced
level in physics myself now so I wasn't
expecting there to be anything new in it
but I did learn a few things and I
thought the presentation of it was
really engaging it's very American take
from that what you will but it's a
really interesting way of getting these
concepts across particularly seeing as
so many people who are interested in
physics are obviously kind of sci-fi
nerds I'm one of them
using kind of sci-fi tropes and
background like for example Star Trek
Star Wars it's a great way of getting
these relatively high level ideas to a
younger audience so this one I think is
a really good idea for a present for
somebody who's a little bit younger
maybe kind of sort of 14 to 18 kind of
range but I read it as a PhD student and
I enjoyed it so generally I think this
want to be a good as a as a present then
to round out the popular science books
we've already had one about relativity
so this one is gonna be about the other
massive pillar of 20th century physics
quantum by Manjit Kumar now I'll be
honest with you I don't know if I have
found the book on quantum mechanics I
don't think one exists really of the
ones I've read this is the closest to
being the book and I think the reason
for that is this introduces quantum
mechanics in a historical way so what I
mean by that is it starts with Max
Planck and his reluctant revolution at
the turn of the century and then builds
up what happened in the field
layer-by-layer von logically now that's
just the way my brain works I found that
to be the best way to get the ideas into
my head I could sort of situate them
that way if you are more interested in
learning things kind of in a conceptual
way then I might recommend in search of
Schrodinger's cat by John Gribben or
alternatively the elegant universe by
Brian Greene though that one is really
about string theory rather than in
quantum mechanics but it necessarily
introduces a lot of quantum stuff too so
this is really a matter of personal
preference I will definitely say that
this is well written is well researched
it's very interesting and it kind of it
struck my resonant frequency of learning
if you like so if you like me maybe
would learn things best in a
chronological way I'd recommend this if
not check the description for the links
to those other two books now before
moving on to the textbooks if you are
interested in learning how to study
physics then I just made a video on that
very subject with the lovely people at
Socratic er so in that video I talk
about my experiences studying physics
how I got into it how I arrived at my
PhD
filled about miss Ferrett physics a bit
about math star used but about
programming that I used and then also a
little bit about looks so if that sounds
interesting to you then definitely check
it out there'll be a card on the screen
and there's also a link in the
description
next up though I'm gonna recommend you
for textbooks and then also a bonus book
which is kind of halfway between the two
categories first the single best most
influential math textbook I've ever used
mathematical methods for physics and
engineering by Riley Hobson and bents
this meaty thing was the Bible of maths
during both of my degrees and it's quite
telling actually that this is the only
math textbook I own because in it I have
all the maths that are used in my Oxford
physics decree so that's everything from
high school level maths to integral
equations tensors PDEs basically if it's
not a graduate level you name it it's in
this book the best part about it is that
there are loads and loads of exercises
at the end of each chapter with the
solutions to half of them at the end of
this book and then you can buy the other
half the solutions to the other half in
a separate volume that's just how many
questions there are and of course doing
those questions is the best way to learn
a new topic so I mean for that reason
alone if you're going to buy one math
textbook to support a physics degree or
to get ahead before a physics degree
it's it's gonna be this one next up a
broad introductory physics textbook
fundamentals of physics by Halliday
Resnick and Walker this was a textbook
which I used a fair bit in my first year
studying physics and I don't actually
own a copy because of that because my
college library in Oxford have enough
copies that everyone could have their
own so I don't own it but I probably
wouldn't used it too much past first
maybe second year it's quite an
introductory quite broad but shallow
textbook about pretty much all the areas
that you expect to cover in a physics
degree but you wouldn't want to just
rely on it it's certainly well made like
it's well presented great figures I just
remember it being particularly like kind
of pleasant to work with but not
the most detailed book so perhaps this
would be great for somebody who is in
high school like a level or IB and
they're not challenged enough by the
course they maybe want to take it a
little bit further so this would be a
good way to bridge the gap between high
school level and university level
physics but like I say I've personally
found it a little bit shallow third and
flipping back to maths a book which I've
not used extensively myself but
everybody seems to have read it and
loved it and so I basically feel obliged
to pay this forward Grant div curl and
all that by H M Shea now there is a
reason why I am recommending this
textbook despite not having used it very
much myself and that's because this is a
textbook about vector calculus so grab
div and curl other three operations the
key operations in vector calculus and
it's a subject which is super super
important in physics like particularly
my field atmospheric physics use it all
the time but it's not terribly well
treated in the literature you don't
learn it in high school and it's kind of
thrust on you at university level so I'm
recommending this because I think it's
an important mathematical thing to add
to toolkit and this is apparently it was
recommended by Oxford University
fortunately I didn't need to act on that
recommendation because for some reason
it just clicked which never happens with
me but this is the book that I would
recommend to if you want to focus in on
like one mathematical technique to
leapfrog your game before you go to uni
or if you're at uni and you are
struggling with vector calculus grad
Dave Cohen all that would be an
excellent place to start and then lastly
another physics textbook and in my
opinion an underrated gem concepts in
thermal physics by Blundell and blundell
now I had the distinct pleasure and
privileged to be lectured by both
Blundell and
blundell they were a husband-and-wife
team and this book is based on one of
their lecture courses on thermodynamics
and statistical mechanics and it's quite
a condensed textbook but it's super easy
to read it covers a key area in physics
a bit similar to grab div and curl this
is an area of physics that if you want
to get ahead in the
game thermodynamics is a fantastic way
to do that that's that's a really useful
subject area and this particular
textbook isn't that intimidating because
it's quite small it covers the same
material but what it also does is
harking back to what I said about
quantum it introduces a historical
context to the concept because
thermodynamics is relatively dry and
what it does is at the end of every
chapter include a biography of a key
player like James Clerk Maxwell or
Carnot or Boltzmann and for me that
added a lot of interest it helps that
the rest of the textbook is really
really well-written and engaging and I
just found super easy to learn from but
the biographies really added something
extra so you definitely recommend this
as a textbook for thermodynamics if
you're taking that course or if you are
someone who wants to get ahead for a
physics degree this is really more
people should read it so that's the
textbooks we've already had the popular
science books so that just leaves us
with the bonus book which doesn't fit
neatly into either of those categories
and that book is the visual display of
quantitative information by Edward Tufte
so this book was given to me at the very
start of my PhD in the very first week
by my supervisor and I had trouble
categorizing it because it kind of is a
textbook specifically it's a textbook
about how to make good figures and it's
the kind of thing that you might refer
to in a course on I don't know
graphic design but it's not something
that you'd use in a physics degree so
it's something that I read as a popular
science book it was something to
supplement my learning and I can
definitely say without a doubt that this
book made me a better scientist this
book made me think for the first time
really about how I was putting together
my figures and it provides you with a
bunch of rules that all kind of
guidelines that you should follow in
putting together a figure and also
things that you should avoid doing so
it's a genuinely practical book and it
also provides you with lots of examples
of where things go right and where
things go wrong and that is a key part
of being a scientist when you have to
present your work no one's gonna want to
look at it if it's just hard to read or
ugly
my supervisor game
but because he thought that everybody
starting a PhD should read it and use
its ideas in making their thesis I did I
got some great feedback on my thesis and
people saying that it was very easy to
read I definitely agree with him I think
this is an important book to read if
you're thinking of becoming a scientist
or if you're supposed just interested in
graphic design but definitely another
underrated book that scientists should
be reading to repeat what I said
at the start of the video there will be
links to the Amazon pages for all of
these books in the description so if you
found any of them interesting definitely
check them out and also recommend that
if I missed your favorite physics book
then put that down in the comments below
of course if you enjoyed the video do
give it a like share the video if you
think other people should see it and
also if you'd like to hear about how I
think about learning physics then
definitely check out the video I made
with Socratic oh thank you for watching
I'll see you next time